hey everyone welcome to another
installments of Harry Potter Theory
today's video is going to be discussing
the five richest Wizarding families in
the entire Wizarding World let's get
into the video the concepts of money and
Status make appearances all over the
place in the Harry Potter story starting
right at the beginning in the very first
book we get Draco boasting about his
family's wealth we get the impression
that perhaps Ron and Louise's aren't
doing quite so well to top it all off we
get to see Harry's absolutely ridiculous
stack of gold inside Vault 687 at
Gringotts Gringotts Wizarding Bank was
the sole financial institution for The
Wizarding community in Great Britain and
was run by goblins it was established in
1474 by a goblin named gringod and a Ted
gortis was located in the North side of
Diagon Alley London the bank served as a
storage facility for Wizarding money and
valuables and provided an easy way for
wizards and witches to exchange Mughal
currency for Wizarding money they this
is demonstrated by Hermione Granger's
parents when they traded muggle money
for Wizarding money to pay for her
school supplies now provided that
Gringotts handles the cash flow with
nearly Every Witch and Wizard in the
magical world there must be some
seriously immense vaults full of gold
kicking about in the World of Harry
Potter there are many wealthy Wizarding
families but only a select few can claim
the title of the richest today we'll be
exploring the top 5 richest Wizarding
families and delving into their immense
wealth their ancestral homes and their
powerful magical legacies to buckle up
and get ready to be transported into the
world of Wizarding wealth and luxury
number 5. gilderoy Lockhart in 1982
British wizard gildoro Lockhart finally
graduated from Hogwarts at which point
he began traveling all around the world
shortly after graduating he began to
build prominence as an author telling
his readers Tales of his heroism and
illustrious magical ability these same
Tales eventually brought him
considerable Fame and as it turns out
Fortune he was a dark wizard catcher a
dragon Tamer a troll conqueror there was
a dark and Powerful presence in the
world Lockhart had vanquished it all by
himself the catch only he was there to
witness it after each and every time
Lockhart traveled he would return home
with a new book filled with
self-promotion heroism and extravagance
and it really left a positive impression
on the magical population he'd hold book
signings all over the magical world and
people loved to be near Lockhart in fact
you can go anywhere without seeing
Lockhart's face or novel plastered all
along the insides of shop windows so
what's my point well Lockhart became
Filthy Rich of course through his book
sales he was able to live a luxurious
lifestyle traveling the world staying in
fancy hotels and wearing expensive
clothing 4. Harry Potter Harry Potter's
wealth and the Harry Potter story is
certainly no secret and Rick exposed to
it as early as he Philosopher's Stone
when were first introduced to Vault 687
and Gringotts Harry has piles and piles
of gold and his immense wealth is
mentioned time and time again throughout
the Harry Potter story but obviously
since Harry was just a wee land the
money wasn't earned by him but that
certainly doesn't mean that Harry didn't
have a plethora of wealthy ancestors as
it turns out the Potter family Fortune
started with the founding patriarch of
the family then Fred of dinschcombe
revolutionary potioneer that began to
amass riches in the Potter name
following him in the family business was
flea montpotter Harry's grandfather who
had all sorts of success of his own in
short Harry had fat sacks of cash but
his fortune only grew after the death of
Sirius Black the black Fortune was
immense and though Sirius didn't have
access to all of it he certainly wasn't
skint this meant that after his death
all of the money went to Harry making
him one of the richest Wizards in The
Wizarding World 3. the malfoys the
malfoys always seem to be praised as
wealthy individuals right that's correct
but interestingly as it turns out the
generational wealth that the Malfoy's
possess started with the wizard named
Armand Malfoy who arrived in Britain
with William the Conqueror having
rendered unknown shady and almost
certainly magical services to King
William the first Malfoy was given a
prime piece of land in Wiltshire seized
from local landowners upon which his
descendants have lived for 10
consecutive centuries having land
ownership so early on in history gave
them a rather advantageous start and
this is reinforced by Pottermore the
result is that they are one of the
richest Wizarding families in Britain
and it had been rumored for many years
though never proven that over the
centuries the family has dabbled
successfully in Mughal currency and
assets 2. Bellatrix and rodolfus the
strange the old Goblin obeyed pressing
his palm to the wood and to the door of
the Vault melted away to reveal a
cave-like opening crammed from floor to
ceiling with golden coins and goblets
silver armor skins of strange creatures
some with long spines others with
drooping Wings potions in jeweled the
skull still wearing its Crown the above
passage of course describes the entrance
to the Vault of none other than
Belichick's to Strange Bellatrix
Lestrange was a pure blood witch that
hailed from the black family and later
married into the pure blood Lestrange
family both the black family and the
strange families were wealthy in their
own right both stemming from the sacred
28 a directory of truly pureblood
families that still existed within the
Wizarding World each family was
immensely wealthy with old money passing
down from generation to generation
Bellatrix and her husband rodolfus ended
up with a large portion of the money
from both family trees and the
combination of these fortunes made them
some of the richest people in the entire
Wizarding World of a shadowing even the
malfoys number one Nicola Flamel you
probably didn't guess this one Nikola
Flamel was a French crime born in the
1300s in the city of pontoir on a
day-to-day basis Flamel worked as a
scribe into manuscript Cellar and ran
two shops offering these services in
Paris Flamel achieved a great deal of
success in his career and as a result
became quite wealthy however that's not
where the real money came from you see
Flamel an alchemical Master created an
object named the Philosopher's Stone the
Philosopher's Stone is a legendary
alchemical substance that has the power
to turn ordinary Metals into gold the
process of transforming base Metals into
gold is known as transmutation and was
one of the central goals of alchemy the
Philosopher's Stone was believed to have
the ability to perform this
transmutation quickly and efficiently as
well as bestow eternal life and youth
upon the person who possesses it in the
World of Harry Potter the Philosopher's
Stone is also capable of producing an
elixir of Life which can cure all
diseases and Grant immortality to the
Drinker in creating gold the Stone Works
by using its immense magical power to
alter the molecular structure of the
metal causing it to transform into gold
Flamel of course eventually dies but in
the 666 or 670 odd years that he existed
on the planet I'm sure he had one or two
opportunities to turn objects into gold
in fact I'm linked to bed decapitalized
on it add that to the already immense
wealth that he and perganel held and
well we've got a winner
if you guys want more of a deep dive
into the Harry Potter family wealth then
check out my video why were Harry's
parents so rich
similarly if you want an explanation as
to why all wizards aren't Rich shouldn't
it be easy check out my video why are
some Wizards poor what do you guys think
did I miss anyone would you rearrange
this list comment down below until next
time it does not do to dwell on dreams
and forget to live